We've led hundreds of comprehensive, at scale transformation efforts.
And through these efforts,...
...we've identified four of the most common pitfalls....
...that undermine success.
The first is a failure to set fact based, high aspirations.
Rather than seeking to achieve the potential of their organizations,...
...some leaders aim too low,...
...with a target that simply isn't backed up by the facts.
Second, organizations often fail to attach a compelling "why?"...
...to that new, more aggressive aspiration.
Leaders need to provide all of their employees with a reason...
...why they should do things differently.
A third cause for transformation failure is poor execution.
Too often, managers focus on the activities surrounding the transformation...
...rather than remaining laser-focused on the outcomes.
Finally, organizations often fail to sustain the impact that they've achieved.
Performance disciplines end with the transformation effort,...
...incentives and budgets are not fully aligned with the new objectives,...
...and management teams fail to keep investing in the future,...
...leaving them unprepared for the next horizon or unforeseen headwinds.